because you've made a lot of mistakes
that i think
like i feel like you've made a lot of
mistakes for a whole generation of
rappers to see like hey look
this is what happens when this this and
this yeah bro that's all you could do
you know i just give them games bro
that's what i get
you know you gotta learn from yourself
that's what anybody you gotta learn from
your own mistake
i was gay game you know people gave me
game but i was still
ignorant towards how i wanted to feel
and how i wanted to live so
i just give them game i get all the
youngster game you know especially if i
see a little bit of them and me
i give them game cause i don't want them
to go through what i went through you
know so
yeah i mean i think like uh the biggest
artist out of your city
since you is obviously young boy you
know what i'm saying
yeah he's that i mean on youtube i mean
with the kids don't say my city
no i'm saying but out of the biggest
dude to come out is i mean no in the
world for sure
this dude's been running youtube for
like five straight years but like what's
your relationship like with young boy at
this point in time know that's my people
you know what i'm saying uh
that's my people you know he's going
through a little situation now but he's
gonna
he's gonna be back he's gonna be back
stronger than ever huh
he's gonna be back stronger than ever he
just you know everybody you gotta sit
down sometime
very similar like in as far as just like
come ups with you like obviously he's
right right i see a lot of him and me
yeah
i see a lot of him and me you know going
through all the stuff he went through in
the
in the city you know all the baby mamas
and
you guys have a lot of similarities and
obviously he's locked up when he gets
out he's that that comeback yeah it's
gonna be crazy yeah
yeah yeah i just i i wrote him i wrote
him the other day you don't say have you
talked you talked to him since he's been
locked
yeah i wrote them i talked to him for a
couple minutes but i wrote them and
i wrote him and gave him some positive
words you know what i'm saying and uh
just told him you know what i'm saying
now you're gonna get greater later how
important is that like being in jail
like knowing like having people check in
because i don't think a lot of people
realize like how lonely man a letter
make you man a little make your whole
mind bro you know from somebody or just
a talk on the phone
cause i remember i think i think you and
i talked to you and you had said that
like jeezy had constantly checked in
with you when you were yeah when you
were incarcerated yeah that meant
i mean that meant a lot to me anybody
who who reached out to me that meant a
lot to me because you know you'd be
feeling like you lost in there sometime
when
you don't hear from somebody who
contacted you every day for a year
you'd be feeling like you know [ __ ] you
couldn't find a way to contact me or
contact my people
right so that's what i do even if i
don't hear hear from nobody
i'm gonna reach out to reach out reach
out my hand
it's crazy because um you know and
that's the same thing with anybody i
i if i rock with you and you go to jail
that's how i feel
i'm obligated you know what i'm saying
because you've been on you've been on
the other side
on the other side you know [ __ ] with
money who i [ __ ] with i used to
like damn [ __ ] you ain't gave my mama
you ain't getting nobody nothing
right right you know i know how i feel
sometimes like damn
it's almost like you go you just posted
250 [ __ ] you can't give me
put 1500 on my books you know what i'm
saying you want to
you don't know that to you on the
outside looking in that's why
[ __ ] you ain't nobody got to
contact me i'm to show up